AHEAD.
FOR THE MOMENT AMAZING.
AS JUDICIAL, NO ONE IN D.C.
PREDICTED IT.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: A LOT MORE ON
THIS BREAKING STOFFER LATER
IN THE SHOW.
IMMIGRATION, SLEEPER ISSUE
OF THE 2016 ELECTION.
NO ONE IN POWER ON EITHER
SIDE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT IT
BUT VOTERS DID.
THEY KNEW OUR IMMIGRATION
POLICY WAS NOT SERVING THEIR
INTERESTS AND THAT'S WHY
DONALD TRUMP WON.
YOU THINK BOTH PARTIES WOULD
HAVE LEARNED SOMETHING FROM
THAT EXPERIENCE, KIND OF A
BIGGS DEAL.
AND THE MESSAGE WAS CLEAR.
VOTERS DON'T WANT OPEN
BORDERS AND THEY HAVE SAID
SO EMPHATICALLY.
CONGRESS IS STILL NOT EVEN
PRETENDING TO LISTEN.
MANY REPUBLICAN MEMBERS ON
THE HILL ARE STILL PUSHING
FOR A MASS AMNESTY UNDER THE
ORWELLIAN TITLE OF
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
DEMOCRATS HAVE GONE
COMPLETELY OFF THE DEEP END.
20 YEARS AGO BILL CLINTON
GAVE SPEECHES INCLUDING THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS
CALLING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
A DANGER TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
BECAUSE IT WAS,
DEMONSTRABLY.
TRY SAYING THAT NOW AT A
DEMOCRATIC FUNDRAISING
DINNER, YOU WOULD BE DRAGGED
OFF THE STAGE AND CHARGED
WITH BIGOTRY.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
AFFIRMATIVELY IN FAVOR OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT.
THEY TRIED TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THEY CLAIM IMMIGRATION LAWS
THAT CONGRESS PASSED WITH
THEIR SUPPORT ARE NOW
ILLEGITIMATE AND THAT THE
OFFICERS CHARGED WITH
ENFORCING THOSE LAWS ARE
FASCIST.
AND, OF COURSE, THEY HAVE
MADE ALL RATIONALE
CONVERSATION IMPOSSIBLE BY
FRAMING THE ENTIRE ISSUE AS
A BATTLE IN SOME SORT OF
LARGER RACE WAR.
IT'S SHOCKING BUT THAT'S NOT
AN EXAGGERATION.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
TRYING TO DISTRACT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM A
FAILED IMMIGRATION SYSTEM BY
PAINTING A RACIST, BROAD
BRUSH OF OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY AS DANGEROUS
CRIMINALS.
>> THE RACES WHO ARE DRIVING
IMMIGRATION POLICY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE DIVIDING THE
AGENDA FOR EVERY HOUSE
REPUBLICAN AND ARE SHAPING
THE BRAND OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY NOT JUST AS A PARTY
WHO DOESN'T WANT POOR OR
LATIN AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS
BUT DOESN'T WANT BROWN OR
BLACK OR ANYONE WHO ISN'T
WHITE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> SINCE LAST NIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT PUT FORTH A PLAN.
THAT PLAN IS A CAMPAIGN TO
MAKE AMERICA WHITE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: THE PLAN SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT, OF COURSE,
WOULD HAVE ADMITTED
3 MILLION NONWHITE
IMMIGRANTS.
TALK ABOUT DEMAGOGUERY.
THEY NOT ONLY THE
PRO-ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
POLICY THEY DON'T WANT THE
BORDER SECURED.
THEY DEPOSE TOLL DEPORT
ANYONE AFTER CRIMINAL
OFFENSES.
THEY PASS INSTATE
TELEVISION.
FIGHT IMMIGRATION LAW.
THEY THINK KATE STEINLE'S
KILLER HAS MORE RIGHTS THAN.
DO YOU CONFRONT THEM ON ANY
OF THIS THEY SAY AMERICAN
CITIZENS ARE NOT IMPRESSIVE
ENOUGH.
TOO FAT, TOO LAZY, TOO
ADDICTED TO DRUGS.
THEY DEMAND DECENT WAGES.
THEY INSIST ON
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS LIKE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS.
ALL VERY INCONVENIENT.
BILL KRISTOL SAID THAT OUT
LOUD.
LIKE TO SEE THESE PEOPLE
REPLACED BY COMPLIANT
FOREIGNERS.
SERVE THE RULING CLASS
WITHOUT COMPLAINT.
DO VOTERS ACTUALLY SUPPORT
ANY OF THAT?
ACTUALLY THEY DON'T.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
DEMOCRATS KNOW IF THEY
IMPORT ENOUGH NEW VOTERS
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO RUN THE
COUNTRY FOREVER.
WOULD YOU WANT TO LIVE IN
THAT COUNTRY?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS
RECENTLY TOLD THE REST OF US
THAT CALIFORNIA, HER STATE,
IS OUR FUTURE.
LISTEN.
>> THESE FOLKS ARE REALLY
MIRED IN ROLLING BACK THE
CLOCK IN TIME, AND THAT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE
FUTURE.
AND THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
BUT THERE YOU GO.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT BUT
CALIFORNIA IS OUR FUTURE
SAYS FUTURE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE KAMALA HARRIS.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN
ACTUALLY IF THE FUTURE WERE
CALIFORNIA?
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE POVERTY
THAN ANY STATE.
HIGHEST NUMBER OF RESIDENTS
THAT DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH AT
HOME.
ACCORDING TO U.S. NEWS IT
HAS THE LOWEST QUALITY OF
LIFE IN THE COUNTRY.
50 OUT OF 50 STATES.
HOUSING PRICES ARE TOTALLY
OUT OF CONTROL.
HOMELESSNESS IS OVERWHELMING
GO THERE AND SEE FOR
YOURSELF.
HYPODERMIC NEEDLES PILING UP
NUT STREET.
MIDDLE CLASS CAN'T FLEE FAST
ENOUGH.
PAST DECADE A MILLION MORE
PEOPLE HAVE MOVED OUT OF
CALIFORNIA THAN HAVE MOVED
IN.
A U-HAUL FROM SAN JOSE TO
PHOENIX COST 10 TIMES AS
MUCH AS A U-HAUL GOING THE
OTHER WAY BECAUSE NO ONE IS
GOING THE OTHER WAY.
THIS IS THE FUTURE THAT
KAMALA HARRIS IS BOASTING
ABOUT.
ALL OF THIS COULD SOON BE A
POLITICAL PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRATS.
MID TERMS ARE COMING THIS UP
FALL.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO WIN
SEATS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE DUMB
MISTAKES.
THEY ARE GOING TO WIN SEATS.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THEY
RETAKE CONGRESS?
ACCORDING TO ALL PREDICTIONS
THEY SHOULD.
THEY DEFINITELY PROMISED
THEIR VOTERS THEY ARE GOING
TO RETAKE CONGRESS.
YET, IN SPITE OF ALL OF
THESE ADVANTAGES THEY MAY
NOT.
THEY MAY FALL SHORT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEIR POSITIONS ON
IMMIGRATION ARE RADICAL AND
CRAZY.
THEY HAVE NO POPULAR
SUPPORT.
IN A DEMOCRACY POPULAR
SUPPORT STILL MATTERS.
BRIAN DEAN WRIGHT IS A
DEMOCRAT AND FORMER CIA
OPERATIVE WHO SAYS THE OPEN
BORDERS AGENDA IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
BRIAN, WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
THAT?
WHY IS IT NOT SUSTAINABLE TO
LET EVERY POOR PERSON IN THE
WORLD MOVE HERE?
>> HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THIS ARGUMENT, THIS DEBATE
HAS REALLY FOCUSED ON THE
PAST.
HOW HAVE PAST IMMIGRANTS
MADE AMERICA'S GREATNESS?
AND INDEED THEY HAVE.
WE ALL HAVE CONNECTIONS I
AGREE.
>> FANTASTIC IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, RIGHT?
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IN THE
NEXT 15 TO 20 YEARS?
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
SOMETHING NOT RELATED OR
CONNECTED TO POLITICS BUT
ACTUALLY TECHNOLOGY.
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING
ROBOTICS, ANIMATION AND
MACHINE LEARNING.
EFFECTIVELY MAKING HUMAN
LABOR LESS AND LESS
IMPORTANT AND RELEVANT.
THAT'S ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
JOBS THAT IMMIGRANTS HOLD
AND BY THE WAY BLUE COLLAR
FOLKS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
INNER CITIES IN PARTICULAR.
PARTICULAR TUCK EXACTLY.
>> THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CAME OUT WITH THIS STUDY IN
LATE 2016 RIGHT BEFORE THEY
LEFT AND THEY SAID LOOK, WE
ARE ON THE VERGE OF LOSING
JOBS IF YOU HAVE THEM UNDER
20 BUCKS AN HOUR, YOU ARE
LIKELY AND I'M QUOTE GOING
TO BE AUTO MATED INTO ON
LESS SENSE.
BASICALLY YOUR JOB IS GOING
TO GO AWAY.
IF YOU EARN LESS THAN 20
BUCKS AN HOUR, YOU CAN
FORGET ABOUT ANY KIND OF
QUALITY OF LIFE, RIGHT?
SO, THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
JOBS THAT IMMIGRANTS TAKE
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO
IMPACT PEOPLE HERE OR PEOPLE
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY TO
INCLUDE A MERIT BASED
SYSTEM.
EVERYBODY CAN HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ON WHETHER
OR NOT WE SHOULD BE DOING
THIS.
BUT, WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT IS DRIVING THIS
CHANGE.
AND THAT CHANGE IS
TECHNOLOGY.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, PREVIOUS
WAIVES OF IMMIGRATION BEGAN
AT THE START OF THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION.
WE'RE AT THE END OF IT.
SO IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
COUNTRY WITH DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC NEEDS.
WHAT YOU JUST SAID, I'M
GOING TO PRINT OUT AND PUT
AT THE TOP OF MY LIST OF
THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT.
THE JOBS THAT PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS OF IMMIGRANTS
HELD ARE GOING TO BE GONE.
SO THIS IS SO OBVIOUS IT
SHOULD BE PARTICULARLY
OBVIOUS TO PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS LEADING
THE TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE.
WHY DOES NOBODY SAY THAT
EVER?
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT THEIR VERY,
VERY CLOSELY.
I WORK WITH AN ORGANIZATION
NOW OR COLLABORATE WITH AN
COLLECTIVE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO YOU TAKE CARE OF
THE PEOPLE ALREADY HERE
REINSPIRE AND ENGAGE WITH
FLY OVER STATES OFFENSIVE
TERMS BUT EMBRACE IT FINE,
LET'S DO THIS.
HOW DO WE FIX THIS COUNTRY
AND ECONOMY SO THAT THEY
WIN?
ALL RIGHT?
ABSENT THAT WHO IS GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE ALREADY HERE?
NEVERTHELESS, IRRESPECTIVE
OF THE FOLKS THAT WE WOULD
BE IMPORTING DOWN THE ROAD.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO PAY FOR
THE TRILLION-DOLLAR PROGRAMS
TO TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE
ALONE NEW FOLKS ABOUT 60%
DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
NOTABLE SKILLS.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM IF ULTIMATELY
THEY ARE NOT PROVIDING A LOT
BACK IN THE ECONOMY.
I THINK FOR THE NEXT FIVE TO
10 YEARS WE HAVE GOT TO BE
FOCUSED ON WHERE THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE HEADED.
BY THE WAY, I HAVE BEEN
SLAMMED BY FOLKS ON THE LEFT
INCLUDING MEDIA MATTERS AND
OTHERS FOR BRINGING THIS
SUBJECT UP.
IT DOESN'T BODE WELL FOR
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: NO, IT DOESN'T.
>> IF ANYBODY'S TO BE ANGRY
ABOUT THIS, REACH OUT TO
PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
LOS ANGELES AND NEW YORK AND
BOSTON WHO ARE CREATING THIS
TECHNOLOGY, TO YOUR POINT.
I MEAN, GET ANGRY AT THEM
FOR CREATING A SYSTEM WHERE
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
MORE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT WHO WE
TAKE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: AND WE ARE ANGRY.
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S
THRILLING TO HEAR SOMEBODY
SAY SOMETHING THAT IS
DEMONSTRABLY TRUE THAT
EVERYONE ELSE IS AFRAID TO